[Musica]
io mi sento un uomo fortunato perché il
mio lavoro di compositore
non sto a farmi girare il mondo ea farmi
incontrare persone che vengono ascoltare
la musica gli permette di confrontarsi e
spesso queste persone sono amanti della
musica o musicisti oppure gente
specializzata altri compositori
non ho però la fortuna di stare di
fronte un pubblico come voi ricco di
diversità per cui non nascondo che mi
sento giustamente emozionata però sono
qui ora con voi qual cosa devo fare per
cui partire subito con una domanda
la creatività
intesa come molto esclusivamente umano
non sempre produce artisti perché per
poter intraprendere un percorso
artistico
oltre al talento e qui non c'è dubbio
oltre allo studio e all'esperienza
necessita anche di un atto di coscienza
coscienza intesa come consapevolezza la
consapevolezza che un gesto un'azione
provoca un emozione infatti se ci
confrontiamo con gli animali
capiamo subito che loro utilizzano la
loro intelligenza il loro spinto per
colmare i loro bisogni primari mangiare
riproduci giustamente rifugio
difficilmente però possiamo dire che il
loro livello di coscienza sia così alto
da potergli permettere di fare un'opera
d'arte
altrimenti significherebbe che il loro
livello evolutivo e paritario quantomeno
quello dell'essere umano
manca ancora un gradino per fare la
differenza e quella differenza cioè
l'arte per il momento riusciamo a farla
solo noi ma che cosa significa per
l'essere umano andare in uno stato
artistico c'è forse bisogno di un
momento di predizione di se stessi di
deliri artistico meglio poetico platone
diceva che il delirio poetico e ispirato
dalle muse che arriva alle soglie della
poesia senza il delirio delle muse
convinto che la soul abilità lo renda
poeta sarà un poeta incompiuto e la
poesia del savio sarà offuscato da
quella dei poeti in delirio
non è per la loro arte che poi ti
compongono le opere ma per il dio che si
impossessa di loro e si possono poi tar
e se ispirati invasati dalla divinità
che fa loro superare l'intelletto e la
tecnica poetica
e fa loro attingere alla sfera
dell'irrazionalità lirica irrazionalità
lirica due parole incompleta
contrapposizione l'irrazionalità è
qualcosa di fugace istantaneo buttato lì
non pensato la lirica è una forma un
contenitore un pensiero platone ci
suggerisce forse che il delirio delle
muse sia un modo per dimenticare ciò che
abbiamo studiato imparato in andare
oltre come si può essere liricamente
irrazionali può essere che il delirio
artistico sia un modo per tornare ad uno
stato animale fra parentesi
vi siete mai sentiti osservati e
voltandovi riscatto avete visto qualcuno
che vi osservava questo poi se nonostate
animale ricapitolando può essere che il
delirio artistico sia un modo per
tornare ad uno stato animale per colmare
un bisogno primario cioè aggiungere a
quella lista di bisogni primari qualcosa
che può fare la differenza tra essere
animali esseri umani in senso emotivo
cioè provare dei sentimenti che vanno
oltre il dovuto per raggiungere qualcosa
che può fare la differenza
l'arte esempio emozionarsi di fronte a
un suono emozionarsi di fronte a un
colore a quanti di noi è successo
questa necessità questo bisogno è
qualcosa a cui l'uomo non può più fare a
meno della bellezza dell'arte è una
sorta di sesto senso che proprio
dell'esser senziente cioè dell'essere
che pensa che è consapevole
avete mai dimenticato la pentola sul
fuoco o siete passati con il rosso
perché rapiti da un'idea alzate le mani
non abbiate paura ci sono solo 300 mila
telecamere rivedono mezzo mondo
mi fa piacere anche io l'ho fatto e come
ho detto all'inizio non pensavo di stare
di fronte un pubblico come voi
potenziali piromani ma va bene così
vi è mai capitato di osservare una
vostra poesia o un vostro dipinto e dire
ma l'ho fatto io li hanno già scoperto
quindi alzate le mani un altra volta se
volete grazie professore berrino molto
gentile dove eravate in quel momento
cosa eravate in quel momento può essere
che in quel momento si sia raggiunto uno
stato animale uno stato primario con
tutti i sensi accesi pronti a carpire
ogni singola emozione ogni singolo
intuizione per trasformare un'idea in un
percorso artistico questo trans
artistico è quello che fa la differenza
l'infezione divina le irrazionalità
lirica di cui il buon platone parlava e
forse un modo per tornare ad uno stato
animale ma con coscienza la parola
cosciente
in latino coscienza enti significa
essere consapevoli a me andrebbe ora di
fare un piccolo gioco con voi per vedere
se riusciamo avere una coscienza di
massa per quanto questa massa è
circoscritta a questa chiesa mi
piacerebbe fare un esperimento
ascoltando i suoni intorno a noi
ed ora ascoltiamo i suoni dentro di noi
essere un artista e soddisfare il
bisogno dell'arte
bisogna avere il coraggio di lasciarsi
andare senza animali
ovviamente con coscienza ma lasciarsi
questa profondità ci porta in alto e ci
permette di ampliare la nostra
sensibilità
ovviamente per fare tutto ciò ho bisogno
di sorpassare un limite che a volte
comporta anche dei rischi ma con
coraggio se ci si lascia andare in acque
sconosciute si può intravedere una nuova
realtà per poi tornare al molo
sant'agostino diceva che
il presente
e proprio i punti il passato ovvero la
memoria il futuro ovvero le infinite
venire entra buoni punti non esistono
per cui cos'è il presente
il presente è un'intuizione per noi
artisti questo viaggio onirico di dire
dei nostri sogni vive dell'introspezione
vive della ricerca tutti i giorni
dell'intuizione bisogna lasciarsi andare
ai sensi animali per poterli dominare
con l'intelletto
in questo modo noi possiamo ampliare la
nostra visione è vedere il mondo dei
sogni che prende forma tutti
potenzialmente siamo artisti ma quanti
di noi si alzano la notte perché rapiti
da un intuizione per fare le cose
bisogna farle
infatti si dice che l'arte ci renda
liberi ma liberi da che cosa diceva
mafalda in una vignetta che avevo letto
qualche tempo fa da qualche parte
personalmente penso che l'arte ci renda
liberi dalle sovrastrutture che la vita
ci mette davanti tutti i giorni
penso che ci renda liberi e ci rende
sensibili cioè con tutti i sensi accesi
come gli animali infatti vi racconterò
un fatto personale
mi trovavo a malta ma non vacanza quindi
rilassato
una mattina molto presto e non dormi
veglia è un certo punto sono saltato sul
letto perché avevo trovato la parola
giusta
taci
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie